Welcome to
Google Developers Hackademy.
This is the fifth and last part
of the Google Apps Script course
by Antonio Guzman
from GDG Androidtitlan.
If this is your first contact
with the courses,
I recommend you watch them
in order and do the exercises.
Welcome to the fifth
and last lesson
of the Google Apps Script
introduction course.
I'm Antonio Guzman.
In this lesson
we will review
what we've achieved
in the previous sessions.
In lesson one
we got familiarized
with the definitions
of App Script,
with the necessary elements
to write programs,
and with the services available
in the platform.
So, let's remember that GAS
is a way to automate tasks
in a simple way,
a way to manipulate information
we have in our Google Apps.
It's JavaScript, but running
on the server's side,
on Google servers.
And we also have an editor
which we can access
through a web browser.
In lesson 2 we viewed
the types of scripts:
stand alone,
container-bound,
container extension,
web apps,
Google site gadgets
and spreadsheet custom function.
We focused the exercise we did
in a stand alone script
and we worked
with the manual
and time-trigger executions.
During lesson 3,
we worked with
container-bound scripts
and checked the options
in Tools menu.
We integrated our script
into a spreadsheet
and we automated its execution
upon an event:
the opening of that spreadsheet.
This type of scripts don't work
only with Spreadsheet,
they can also be integrated
into Documents.
In lesson 4,
we worked with several
Google Apps services.
We worked with Google Forms,
we worked with Gmail,
with Spreadsheet
and with Documents.
Besides, we integrated
another type of scripts,
the container extension scripts,
which allowed us
to create the menu
with which we triggered
the task.
Google Apps Script allows you
to customize and extend
the functionality
of Google Apps.
But remember,
what we saw in this course
are just some possibilities,
There are more scenarios
you will face day by day,
whether it's in personal
or business environments.
Don't forget to visit
the Google Developers site.
There you'll find
documentation and examples,
and that will allow you
to build better scripts.
I'm Antonio Guzman,
thank you for having followed
this introduction course.
Keep on programming.